[Musique]
Benoît d'avrou présente son exposition
intitulée arbre endémique au jardin
botanique de la Réunion 15 photographies
qui invite à un voyage initiatique à la
rencontre du patrimoine naturel des
forêts
réunionnaises en fait c'est une
exposition qui a
commencé à Saint-Joseph et et en fait on
m'a proposé de faire un travail sur les
arbres endémiques
euh vu qu'il avait pas vraiment eu des
travail photographique qui av été des
fait fait dessus en fait du coup j'ai
commencé à bosser un petit peu vers
Saint-Philippe et puis après en allant
un peu dans les haut avec un ami à moi
qui est botaniste qui m'aidait à repérer
un peu les espèces et puis après ben je
commencé à lancer une sorte de schéma de
travail on va dire où je partais en
repérage
ensuite je revenais en général de jours
pour essayer de faire la photo et puis
en fonction de la météo je revenais
sinon de nuit pour pour PIR faire les
prises de vue après de années passé à
l'École supérieure d'art de la réunion à
expérimenté le sujet Benoît d'avrou suit
un cursus photographique au Québec où il
réalise ses premières expositions à son
retour à La Réunion Isabelle o de
l'association passage formation lui
propose ce projet connaissait déjà
depuis quelques temps elle savait que je
faisais de la photo et en fait c'est
elle qui m'a appelé en me disant
chercher quelqu'un pour faire des photos
d'arbres principalement des espèces
endémiques et puis ensuite à travers son
son
association on a pu enfin elle a pu me
donner quelques subventions pour pouvoir
imprimer mes premiers tirages et puis
pouvoir faire ma première exposition qui
a été faite au Cau à Saint ce sont des
heures de travail qu'il a fallu à
l'artiste pour mettre en scène ses 15
clichés où l'arbre est représenté de
manière fantasmagorique c'est peut-être
pas forcément ma préférée après c'est
vrai que c'est l'image que je trouve qui
fonctionne le mieux dans la série
visuellement parlant en fait et puis je
crois que c'est la première image que
j'ai faite de nuit dedans toute la série
donc ça a été vraiment un tournant
celle-là j'y suis retourné trois fois il
me semble vu que les trois fois il s'est
mis à pleuvoir dans la nuit sans
Philippe et du
coup en revenant la dernière fois j'ai
pu réaliser l'image j'ai ramené des
spots lumineux j'ai pu éclairer l'arbre
et puis à peu près on va dire le temps
d'arriver à faire correctement
l'image ça prend faut arriver quand il
fait jour permettre de faire le cadrage
en pleine journée de régler un peu tous
les tout ce qui est technique et puis
ouais à peu près 3 He on va dire on a
une image comme ça l'exposition arbre
endémique est présentée au jardin
botanique de la Réunion jusqu'au 21 août
[Musique]